[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts professor
coronis quirrell his appointment as
defence against the dark arts professor
and whether or not dumbledore knew that
quirrell was possessed by voldemort
all along corones quirrell was an
english half-blood wizard
born sometime in the 1960s when he was
of age
he began attending hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
at which point he was sorted into
ravenclaw house
quirrell was a highly unusual and
delicate but
talented student and was teased
profusely at school making the anxious
quarrel
even more anxious his feelings of
inadequacy
led to him taking a particular interest
in the dark arts
a highly complicated and dangerous field
of magic that could perhaps garner
quirrell the attention
and respect that he always longed for
for the duration of his studies
he showed a particular affinity for the
dark arts and he ended up graduating
from hogwarts with impressive grades
across the board
it wasn't very long after he himself had
graduated
that he was able to secure a job as
muggle studies professor
at hogwarts it's not actually known how
long krill was in that particular
position for
but during his time working as a
professor at the school he had a
reputation for being extremely
neurotic this likely originally stemmed
from his childhood bullying
and it's unfortunate that it followed
him into adulthood
as it had a profound effect on the
actions that he would take as a grown
man
in the year 1990 cruel took a year-long
sabbatical
he told his peers that the sabbatical
was an opportunity for him to gain
first-hand experience in the field where
in reality
his objective was to find lord voldemort
exceedingly curious about what had
happened
to the dark lord who tyrannised the
wizarding world for years
on end it was a trip that would change
coral
and destroy what was left of a man
haunted by his youth
coral always wanted to be noticed and
acknowledged he wanted to earn people's
respect
and he felt that if he was the one to
track down lord voldemort
then he could finally earn the attention
that he longed for
and find voldemort he did however things
didn't go exactly according to plan
voldemort recounts his first meeting
with quirrell
a wizard young foolish and gullible
wandered across my path in the forest i
had made my home
oh he seemed the very chance i'd been
dreaming of for he was a teacher at
dumbledore's school
he was easy to bend to my will he
brought me back to this country
and after a while i took possession of
his body to supervise him closely
as he carried out my orders and when
krill returned to hogwarts school
after traveling the other professors
seemed to notice that he wasn't quite
the same hagrid recounts crowl's nature
after returning home
from his travels oh yeah poor bloke
brilliant mind
he was fine while he was studying out of
books but then he took a year off
to get some first-hand experience they
say he met vampires in the black forest
and there was a nasty bit of trouble
with the hag never been the same since
when krill began teaching again at
hogwarts he didn't resume his previous
role
as muggle studies professor instead he
began his new
role as defense against the dark arts
professor quirrell being assigned to
this role was a questionable decision
particularly as the far more suited
professor snape
would have snapped it up in a second it
was crawl's first year in the role
and it was subject to controversy
stemming from kroll's apparent
incompetency and meek demeanor while
teaching
his lack of confidence was apparent even
to the student body
so why on earth did dumbledore appoint
quirrell
as defense against the dark arts
professor isn't dumbledore supposed to
be the wise old all-knowing wizard
that never makes a mistake how could he
have made such a glaringly obvious
error in judgment defense against the
dark arts isn't all about theory
it also requires immense strength of
character something which quarrel was
seriously lacking in
what's the deal jk rowling once stated
that quarrel's special ability was that
he was
learned in the theory of defensive magic
but
less adept in the practice what this
tells me is that krill wasn't
incompetent or
unwise he was just not a good
practitioner of the magic that he taught
his focus was theory while being able to
actually practice what you preach
can be valuable i don't necessarily
think that it's essential
and i feel the quill's knowledge in the
subject of dark arts
backed by his tenacious attitude toward
learning would have been
more than enough to convince dumbledore
of his suitability for the role
here's the other thing dumbledore
probably knew that quirrell was
voldemort all along
i say this because first of all
dumbledore always knew that voldemort
would return one day
being the highly perceptive man that he
is i find it hard to believe that he
wouldn't have noticed a drastic change
in the way that quirrell acted
and behaved after his travels dumbledore
also knew
that the defense against the dark arts
position was cursed
which meant that at some point or
another something would happen to
quirrell
dumbledore is also a legitimate which
means that he has the ability to read
people's minds
but i don't think that he uncovered
qural's possession that way
i actually think the opposite in
ordinary circumstances
i suspect that dumbledore would be able
to easily read and invade the mind of a
weaker wizard
like quirrell however i expected while
he was possessed by voldemort
coral's mind would have been uninvitable
the result of lord voldemort's
proficiency
in occlumency no longer being able to
navigate the mind of cruel
would have been a major red flag and i'm
certain that dumbledore knew
that dark magic was at play by the end
of the philosopher's stone
quirrell is quite different indeed to
the point at which his stutter
entirely disappears it was clear that
something was up
and dumbledore was the first to spot it
he knew that krill had travelled to
albania
the last rumored location of voldemort
so he put two and two together
but he didn't have enough evidence to
pin him voldemort possessing cruel
actually worked in damodar's favor
however as dumbledore who knew that
voldemort was eager to get his physical
form back
lured him in with the philosopher's
stone the stone was one of the only ways
that voldemort would be able to return
to his former glory and dumbledore took
advantage of this
it was the perfect bait there was also
very little associated risk
with discovering voldemort in this
fashion as he was a
in a weakened form and b neither
voldemort nor quirrell would have been
able to retrieve the stone on their own
it is expressed by dumbledore that in
order to retrieve the stone
you have to see yourself in the mirror
and want it but
not to use it darmador also had harry
the boy who was completely invulnerable
to voldemort
he knew all along that there was very
little to lose and potentially very much
to gain
by allowing crawl to remain in the
castle as it could result in the
capturing of a dangerous dark wizard
still at large by placing the stone in
hogwarts
dumbledore knew that voldemort wouldn't
be able to resist chance at obtaining it
it was the perfect plan the only real
risk associated with dumbledore's plan
was the
at least in dumbledore's eyes highly
unlikely scenario
in which voldemort and quirrell somehow
use harry to get the stone for them
in an effort to make sure that harry
isn't able to obtain the stone himself
he shows harry the mayor of erised on
purpose earlier on in the school year
when dumbledore stumbles upon harry
gazing into the mirror
harry explains that he sees his parents
this only tells dumbledore that his plan
is safe and sound as this would mean
that he is incapable
of retrieving the stone thus causing
less of a risk
dumbledore of course also baited harry
to the dungeons
knowing that with his mother's loving
sacrifice he stood a very good chance at
defeating the dark lord
however as we know things didn't go
exactly
according to his plan and that's it for
this video
what do you guys think did dumbledore
know that quirrell was possessed all
along
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
you